Speaker 1: The number one puppetmaster and this
is really their word, not mine. That is now being
blamed not only for orchestrating Trump's possible
arrest happening Tuesday, but also Ron Desantis's
campaign is this might not come as a surprise.
The nearly 100 year old Jewish man, George Soros.
I know. How could he be controlling everything?
How could it be so effective? It doesn't make any
sense. Well, this is where they're going. We
already have multiple clips from the past few
days where on Fox News and elsewhere, the right
is already starting to say Soros is involved in
what may be the arrest of Trump. Here's one
clip from I believe this is the weekend Fox
and Friends March 19th. Yeah, I believe this
is the weekend Fox and Friends talking about
how Soros and globalists must be to blame here.
So let me ask you the question how many black
lives have you sacrificed under a higher crime
city with increased murder rates? To devote a
limited number of resources to the priority of
pursuing a weak case against Donald Trump? How
many black lives was this political stunt worth?
Speaker 2: What you learn from the left is that
they don't. Really care about Black lives
or the working class or the poor. You know,
this is a George Soros funded day and he has
to pay his master back. And this is exactly.
Speaker 1: What his master folks. This is.
Oh, my goodness. Oh. Just overtly copying
the anti-Semitic rhetoric of the. It's
the Jewish master who must be paid. He
wants money. That money grubbing 90 something year
old multibillionaire George Soros way. That does
that doesn't matter. This is the story.
Speaker 2: George Soros and so many of
those radicals on the left want to have happen to
Donald Trump. They want to put an end to him. You
know, George Soros, a globalist. No question that
Donald Trump and his ideas, which are now being.
Speaker 1: Yeah, globalist, internationalist,
Trotskyite socialist, unlike Obama, Trudeau,
Macron, there it is. And by the way, we'll
get to what Alex Jones thinks about all
this a little bit later. Marjorie Taylor
GREENE also invoking George Soros. They're
all on message. You've got to hand it to them.
Speaker 2: It is a war. It's a political war.
And that is what they've waged against
President Trump, his administration,
his staff, his supporters, and anyone that
aligns himself with MAGA. And what this D.A.,
this Manhattan D.A. is talking about doing,
he is serving his master. Who is George Soros?
Speaker 1: There it is. I mean, folks,
it's quite literally the same language.
This is Marjorie Taylor GREENE on
pillow TV. Earlier, it was, you know,
the weekend second stringers on Fox and Friends,
they are on message, that is for damn sure.
Speaker 2: And the Democrat Party and the
globalist, the late that do not care about
America. They don't care about Americans
anymore. They see Trump as their number one
enemy. And MAGA is the force that they
have to take out. And that is why this
D.A. is considering indicting President Trump.
Speaker 1: All right, so Soros and the globalist
are the ones responsible. But it's not just
for Trump's arrest. They are also claiming that
Soros is responsible for Ron Desantis's potential
candidacy, which hasn't even started yet. There is
a handful of these I could play, but I will only
play one. This is just a random person waiting in
line at Trump's recent event in Iowa, bringing
up Oh no, no, Soros is behind DeSantis. Anybody
talking about any other person for president
other than Donald Trump? Any other name? No, no.
Speaker 2: No, no. I'm talking about Hispanics.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 2: No, no, no. Yeah. And money.
Speaker 1: Soros money.
Yeah. There you go. Soros money is behind DeSantis
as well. So this is there's a lot of scholarship
about this. And just to be like completely
accurate, let me just say 92 years old. Okay,
So he's not quite yet approaching 100,
but he's oh, he's in his nineties. The
idea behind the Soros conspiracy theories, the
person doing it isn't necessarily intending to
promote anti-Semitism. They may not even really
understand the whole back story. But we have to
be realistic. And George Soros is Jewish
identity is widely known and the origins
of many of these conspiracies are linked to those
who understand and or are aware. Now, I know some
of you will say, well, some of these people
don't necessarily know that Soros is Jewish,
I grant you that. But it's still important to
understand that the Soros conspiracy theories
are inextricably linked in to very well-known
anti-Semitic tropes, like, for example,
Soros rich Jewish guy controlling banking or
controlling media or working to destabilize a
country or working to infiltrate modern society
with Marxism or whatever the case may be. And
it all goes back to those anti-Semitic tropes that
many of us know all too well. And that's important
to understand, sort of like the genesis of that.
So Soros really a busy guy now at 92, involved in
Desantis's campaign and Trump's arrest and all of
it. The question next becomes, whatever it is that
these right wingers believe about the possible
arrest of Donald Trump, are they going to riot?